[Music]
Edward Andrew: Le Monde is one of the most important French newspapers
And has always been keen to be the best publishing institution
Online news in France.
Has always represented the challenge we face
Be able to put the best of the press
On the reader machine and tap
Of this technology to reach as many as possible
Of people.
After we learned that a lot of our readers
Consider reading Le Monde as complete
It takes a lot of time
We started thinking about issuing a daily newspaper
Be a digital newspaper with distinction
La Matinale was a newspaper.
Asin Amro: We wanted to go through La Matinale
Test some new things
And change the way we work [inaudible].
Le Monde is an evening newspaper
But we wanted through La Matinale
To publish morning news
Exclusive on mobile devices.
We developed the idea of ​​La Matinale
After we analyzed user feedback on the main Le Monde application.
We discovered two problems:
First in price
The second to allocate a lot of time to read.
Through La Matinale, we managed to solve these problems
By cutting the price of the service and publishing only 20 articles a day.
Android is a platform for La Matinale application.
Since the launch of La Matinale, Android has been launched
The main source of newspaper downloads.
We also noticed an increase in subscribers' remittances
6% on Android compared to other operating systems.
We believe the billing system is on Google Play
Contributed a lot to increasing subscriber transfer rates
To apply La Matinale as we believe the reason for it
Is to provide a better user experience
Compare with the main Le Monde application.
Thanks to the Google Play billing system
The user does not need to fill a lot of models.
Just click a button
To subscribe to La Matinale.
Subscriber transfers on La Matinale
14 times higher than the main Le Monde application.
Hence we realize that the application of La Matinale
Offers a great experience for the reader.
Edward Andrew: The application was La Matinale
The first product we apply
Google Play billing system.
It was very simple.
Application developers took only one week
And when we discovered the success of the experiment
We decided to circulate it to our main application.
Asin Amro: We really wanted to get back
Direct readers of the main Le Monde application
We thought the best way to promote La Matinale
Are across the main Le Monde application.
We placed an ad on the home screen between 7:00 and 9:00
To promote the day edition of La Matinale
With the newspaper logo and the title of which edition
Includes the headlines of today's edition.
In terms of interaction, he was able to apply La Matinale
Achieve great success with multiple Android user visits.
Operating per user is 3.5 times greater
Compared to other operating systems.
That is another standard that proves
How successful La Matinale is in terms of interaction.
Edward Andrew: We think we are now
Need awareness on the application of La Matinale
To get to know more people about its importance
How to submit a few minutes every morning
An overview of the news.
[Music playing]